queremos encontrar el resultado de
dividir 473 entre 5 y como siempre
porque no pausas el vídeo y lo intentas
por tu cuenta y si te es familiar la
idea de la división con cocientes
parciales te encargo que lo intentes de
esa forma
bien vamos a trabajar juntos y déjame
escribir esto de la manera que sea más
fácil para realizar la división con
conscientes parciales así que escribiré
473 dividido entre 5 y lo que es
estupendo de la división con cocientes
parciales es que tenemos mucha
flexibilidad en cómo realizarla no hay
exactamente un único camino correcto
podemos decir cuántas veces cabe el 5 en
473 sin rebasar a 473 no sé tal vez
alguien piense o tal vez caben 100 veces
pero rápidamente puedes ver que si
utilizamos 100 veces y multiplicamos 100
por 5 obtenemos 500 y por lo tanto
debemos decir espera espera espera
espera repasamos a 473 por lo tanto 100
es demasiado entonces tenemos que
regresarnos un poco y pensar en números
menores
poco ajustar sabemos que 5 cabe más de
20 veces en 473 así que empecemos con 20
cuál es el resultado de 20 por 5 bueno
eso es 100 déjame ser claro con esto
este 100 es 20 por 5 como claramente no
existimos a 473 entonces cuántas veces
más cabras 5 en 473 que 20 bueno para
resolver cuantas veces más tenemos que
poner atención en cuanto nos queda para
eso hay que restar 100 de 473 y
obtenemos 373 bien cuántas veces más
cabe 5 en 373 bueno si 20 por 5 100
entonces puedes pensar que este es
cercano a 300 por lo que cabe al menos
otras 60 veces más entonces escribir el
60 en la parte superior y cuál es el
resultado de 60 por 5
bueno seis decenas por cinco es lo mismo
que treinta decenas lo que es
trescientos y que nos queda todavía
bueno nos queda todavía 73 373 menos 373
entonces cuántas veces más cabe el 5 el
73 bueno sabemos que 5 por 12 es 60 así
que déjame intentar con 12 entonces
tengo 12 por 5 lo cual es 60 y que nos
queda todavía bueno 73 menos 60 es 13 y
5 todavía cabe en 13 entonces podemos
agregar algunos cincos más quiero ser
muy claro hemos pensado que es 5 cada 20
veces después otras 60 veces y después
otras 12 veces se 5 entra todas esas
veces en 473 sigue quedando 13 así que
cuántas veces cada vez 5 en 13 bueno 5 x
2 es 10
5 x 3 es demasiado así que podemos
escribir el 2 y decir 2 por 5 es 10 y
nos quedan 3 en este momento ya no caben
más 5 en 3 no podemos dividir 3 por 5
por lo tanto este número es nuestro
residuo y cuántas veces cupo 5 473 bueno
cupo 20 veces y después otras 60 veces y
después otras 12 veces y por último
otras dos veces por lo tanto podemos
sumar todos estos números y que
obtenemos bueno dos más dos es 14 14 60
74 + 20 94 y tenemos un residuo de 3 así
que lo escribiré el resultado es 94 con
un residuo de 3 y lo hicimos bien dos
más dos es 14 74-94 si estamos bien
ahora déjame mostrarte que existe más de
una forma de encontrar este resultado
déjame separar esto para que no te
confundas podemos hacer algo así y
podemos decir cuál es el resultado de
dividir 473 entre 5 y de manera
inmediata puede reconocer que 5 cabe 8
veces en 40 por lo tanto 5 caben 400 al
menos 80 veces tal vez sean más que esas
pero empecemos con 80 ahora que tanto
nos acerca a esto 473 para saberlo
multiplicamos 80 por 5 lo cual es 400
ahora caben más cincos en la diferencia
bueno resolvamos la diferencia antes
déjame ser muy claro estos 80 por 5 la
razón del por qué hice esto fue intentar
acercarnos a 473
lo que queremos saber es cuántos cincos
más caben en lo que queda bueno si
restamos 400 de 473 nos quedan 73 ten
por seguro que caben más 5 173 y que te
así lo intentamos 10 5 es más así que
vamos a agregar otros 10 5 es más y que
tan cerca estamos bueno 10 por 5 50 y
para ser muy claros lo que hicimos aquí
es 10 por 5 ahora caben más 5 en la
diferencia bueno
realizamos la resta para encontrar que
nos queda 73 menos 50 23 y por supuesto
caben más 5 en 23
sabemos que 5 por 4 es 20
así que pondremos 45 más 5 por 42 20 y
pensemos que tan cerca estamos que nos
queda y claro caben más cinco en lo que
nos queda bueno si restamos 20 de 23 nos
quedan 3 y como 3 es menor que 5 no
caben más cincos en él así que ya lo
tienes logramos obtener 85 de 473
después nos dimos cuenta de que aún
quedaba algo así que logramos obtener
otros 10 -cinco de lo que quedaba y
después nos volvimos a dar cuenta de que
aún quedaba algo así que logramos
obtener otros 452 de lo que quedaba y
después nos quedamos con 3 donde ya no
obtuvimos más cincos así que en total
logramos obtener 90 y 45 de 473 y nos
quedó un residuo de 3 que es exactamente
lo que tenemos a la izquierda